somewhere
um
yeah welcome to the plans committee
meeting
for the 12th of january
um before we start i'll get the
committee to introduce themselves
uh start with myself i'm councillor
chris leather
chairs are meeting and i represent
northern and i'll start there with
councillor craig hi
i'm ruth craigie and i represent benefit
east
good morning my name is uh devil from
golf and i represent pedophiles
good morning my name is peter christine
i'm at the benefit north as well
yeah pete watson i represent broady
this morning i'm richard bachman i
represent
and if i can get the officers sat here
and then the officers who are present to
introduce themselves start without
planning management good morning members
members of public my name's sean
harrington i'm the planning manager of
terrorist council
good morning my name is stacy dory i'm
the head of legal governance of georgia
district council
members my name is
good morning
good morning
thank you okay
we're not expecting any fire drill this
morning so as the alarm goes off
please make your way out the way that
you came in but don't use the lift
somebody will take them down we've still
got agents here
can this be turned
[Music]
a little bit closer
[Music]
not very good this system to be honest
uh yeah we're not expecting a fire drill
this morning
um so if we have to leave if the alarm
goes off
he's great the way you came in and down
the stairs but don't use the lift
right
i tomorrow ninja then his apologies for
absent so i think we've got a full
complement this morning
no apologies thank you
and item two
uh on the agenda
is
the minutes of our last meeting on the
second of december
and they're on pages five to nine
that i'll move those from the chairs and
like settle
councillor watson second one
could you take a vote on those please
i was absent thank you councilman
mcgrath
councillor watson oh
councillor wiseman
thank you
that's 74 chair and two extensions thank
you
item 3 on the agenda is declarations of
interest
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature
of their interest when that item is
being considered
elected members of devon county council
and town and parish councils who've
considered a planning application by
virtue of their membership of that
council
hold a personal interest and are deemed
to have considered the application
separately
and the express views of that council do
not bind the members concerned who
consider the application afresh
item 4 is
agreement of the agenda between parts
one and two there is no part two
to the meeting
i can find an urgent matters to be
brought forward without no urgent
matters
the planning manager has either
right item six is public participation
this is where i invite advise the
committee of any prior request to speak
made by members of the public
and to advise of the
details of the council's public
participation scheme
we have got
uh for the first one the lands landed
camps down industrial park
uh christopher young who's going to
speak against he sent a letter in which
will be read by the planning manager
also for the land of cads down
industrial park application
jonathan chick
who is a supporter of the agent
the other speakers listed as the
abbotson road application
brian sims a member of the public will
speak against that
again the land north of robertson road
christina trump bracey
is speaking against again a letter has
been sent in which be read by the
planning manager
and again for the land north of abbotson
road stuart carville in support was the
applicant
and then the final one is the land off
caddywhile and engine torrington
james shuttleworth member of the public
objecting to that application again a
center lettering which will be read by
the planning manager
on the order of speakers
are that
the planning officer will give their
presentation of the application
any town or parish councillor who wishes
to speak
for or against the application
they're given three minutes to speak
and then up to two members of the public
speakers who wish to speak against an
application they have three minutes each
and then there are two members of the
public who can speak in support of an
application
they also have three minutes each
and finally any torres district council
member from the ward in which the
application falls and there is no time
limit on that board member speaking to
an application
so that
concludes the public petition part of
the agenda
item seven is the planning applications
the information recommended
recommendations and advice
contained in the reports are correct at
the date of preparation
which is more than 10 days in advance of
the committee meeting
due to these time constraints
any changes or necessary updates to the
rewards
will be provided in writing
or orally at the committee meeting
so now we move on to our first 7a
application on pages 10 to 96 of your
agenda
the reports there
and
the planning manager is going to present
this application
it comes with christian you know i'm
dual hatted on this one
and i also explained on the extreme east
um there's an area of allotments
um this orders the site
the land is owned by the british trust
on the british trustee and it's rented
by a bit of a town council on town
council but i've got no financial
interest and i've come to it
thanks for that counselor christian
good morning members can you hear me
clearly
[Music]
any
better definitely very close to my phone
so this remembers this application
zero six five six slash twenty twenty
slash outm if my voice space in and out
please let me know and i must be clear
it's an outline application for up to
211 dwellings with up to 4.27 hectares
of commercial land and we use classes b2
b8 and eg public open space and other
associated infrastructure
with all matters reserved except access
therefore masses of appearance
landscaping layout and scale would be
considered considered at later date at
the reserve matters application
before i commence with the body of the
presentation there are a couple of
verbal updates to give to members
the first one is that a late
representation has been received
which has been uploaded to the website
uh this representation raised matters of
consultation
um in that the representation
did uh haven't realized the application
had been submitted
general planning considerations
the scope of the application in terms of
inclusion of an access road up to
buckland road
supposedly employment land
and concerns about noise and disturbance
it's considered that these matters have
been considered within your offices
before
there's also an amendment to condition
seven which is page 55 of your committee
report
and it's a simple typo it should read to
the injections of the allocated bid 09
site as opposed to bid 07
so if the decision from committee was in
line with boss's recommendation we'd
have to seek a amendment to that
condition just to reflect that
environment
the third verbal update is in relation
to appendix one
which is the viability report the
district values viability report
and it's a matter of disregarding
paragraph 13.2 of that report was on
page 67 of the committee which has been
included in error which was hopefully
pointed out by another
so moving on to the leverku presentation
as members can see in front of them this
is a location plan
uh of the site members have had the
benefit of a comprehensive virtual site
visit uh so it should be well aware of
the site and the environs of that site
it occupied occupies approximately 19.9
hectares of agricultural land
which is largely later past year
and incorporates a number of existing
hedgerows and trees along the perimeter
and inside the site
the site is not within a protected
landscape
and there are no west eye destinations
or european wildlife designations on all
around sites
so frontal members now is a context
location of the site um i'm sure members
of where the site is it's fairly close
to where we're all sat now
it's to the south of woody food
and directly adjacent to castle
industrial state
this is a copy of the policies map of
the adopted northern entire local plan
as you can see the allocation for this
site
is the area hatched um on the planet in
front of you
whilst the area in the purple pink color
adjacent is the adjacent allocator side
bit of nine which does benefit from an
outline planning commission and there is
a reserved matters application for
consideration with the authority at the
moment
as members will see from that hatching
the allocation does also include the
electric record centre and the recycling
center which have already been delivered
so more of a side context
from this plan members can see and this
was at the site visit
and receive the context of surrounding
landforms and also the water courses
that run around through the site and
just zoom in on that
members
so surrounding the site we have out
castle
states into industrial park to the north
chile east we have the allotment area as
classic christie mentioned number two
road ordering site to the south
blue water course
and woodland to the far western side of
the site
the allocated sites which adjacent out
his site shown in the hatch
this plan shows the landscape sashi
areas from the site
and essentially the uh the pink areas
are the most physically exposed areas um
with the sort of the yellow beige area
in the most contained area
this just goes to show the topography of
the site which i'm sure members are
aware of from the site visit
um which broadly speaking um runs north
to south but it is a undulating landfill
with the site dropping off quite
significantly to the south the southern
boundary of that site
a landscape visual impact assessment has
been submitted with the application and
companies the application
which has been productive members and
it's online um for members to uh view
the outcome of that visual assessment
indicates that the uh the main clear
view of the site from surrounding
highways and road network is from the
south and there will be a few
photographs later on the presentation to
that
um to the north east and west there are
occasional glimpse views um with the
most prominent view let's say being from
the south due to that landform
as mentioned in the presentation the
application is an outline
except for access
therefore any plans into the application
are indicative at this stage
all of the plans have been fairly
thoroughly worked up so it does give a
very clear indication to officers and
members of the likely layout of the site
but as i say it is indicative
so just running through the site it's
proposed uh addictively that the
commercial land could uh be directly the
south
of the industrial state
with an area of residential to the east
and to the south
and should be aware of the linking road
at spine roads uh from the east to the
west boundary again linking to the
adjacent alligator site
access to the north side onto cleveland
road via roundabout which we'll come on
to in a second which is detailed
so that is for consideration
and also continuation of the access from
capstone industrial state
just to the south of where we sat at the
moment via the tennis center pasadena
center
the addictive plan also shows
attenuation and drainage as well as the
open space strategy and a landscape
strategy again
moving on to some photographs of the
site
so these photographs are on the site uh
with the south um members will know that
there's a site is later pasture
and the topography of the light looking
down towards the south
now this is a view north towards
cleveland road and this is a area of
land where the access would run
and on the photograph there on the right
members will be going to see the
rooftops of bungalows that's our along
the valley road
views west from the site
in the distance you'll be able to see
the green roof of the tennis center
just to get your bearings from the side
views north and beyond this hedge bank
is the recycling center so again it
gives you an indication of that boundary
shipment recycling center
photographs of the woodland to the west
of the site which will be retained
that's protected by condition as you'll
note in your offices reports
um some photographs from the very south
of the site looking south towards
janet's cottage which is grade two
listed i'll point that in a second
um just to indicate the inter visibility
of that um you'll just be able to see
the chimney stack through the
the tree line there which has just
rendered
give you indication of the site levels
as
well views north on the site again uh to
give an appreciation of that open
topography of this area of the site
and the photograph on the right um
facing towards the tennis center and
beyond that uh the castle industrial
state and the actual building we're in
now
as indicated earlier from the landscape
visual
impact assessment
the long distance views are limited
however there are clear views on the
site from the south um and particularly
from this viewpoint
which wasn't highlighted in the virtual
site visit
and if i can zoom in the site
is there in this sort of two triangular
fields really
they're in the center of the view now
uh batman road we've gone to the of
southwest site and these photographs
does give a character of [ __ ] road um
it is very ruined character a single
lane highway
um with the existing main access to the
site
into the northeast of the site
as shown by that gate
so if you view the cleveland road again
i'm sure members are very aware of
trevelli rose and this character
this is a view facing west
with existing dwellings
to the right hand side of the photograph
and the access will be to the left and
this will be the router access which we
can wonder in a second
again a better view of where the access
point will be
members may be able to see just in
distance the howdens building which is
and then a view facing um to the eastern
direction
the access point around about
to the right-hand side photograph
and the dwellings to the left
should know the width for cleveland with
the pavement the distance between those
dwellings
and moving on to the access which will
be via castell
um just a few photographs of this road
which runs past the tennis center
uh top left is the one that's the far
south
which will link down to the site
the bottom right photograph the
indication of the link that will go
towards
the
adjacent allocator site
so let's moving on to the detail plans
said access is detailed
uh in front of members is the plans for
the proposed roundabout
we do have matt collins from devon
county council highways body with us
today if there are any questions about
this
but the roundabout has been considered
has been subject to audit assessment and
is considered suitable
for the access required
quick plan of the green infrastructure
again this is indicative at this stage
i'll come on to the detailed
considerations of this
in a second
but just so members can understand
how the green infrastructure
infrastructure strategy should be
achieved on that side
and there's also a tree removal and
retention plan um certainly from the
site and members will be aware from the
committee report that there are
conditions ensuring that
trees are retained and protected during
construction
um also a landscape strategy uh again
indicating how a landscape actually
could be employed on the site given the
quantum of uh development for both
again landscape would form a matter of
reserve matters
and finally before we come onto
considerations uh the joining
strategy that's been employed and that
has been considered by devon county
council as well
again there are conditions
put forward in the office's report
requiring details of this to be
submitted
so moving on to the main client
considerations of relevance remember
still gaming clearly
yeah
so in terms of principal development
in policy terms the entire site is
located within the development boundary
for biddeford
and policy st06 of the adopted local
plan identifies biddeford as a strategic
center which will provide a focus for
housing and employment development
the application site performs the
majority of an allocation for housing
and commercial development as prescribed
within policy bid 05
video 5 for the texas beta 5 is included
in your committee report so i won't
repeat that um however some parts of
video five i will in relation to our
highlight relation to the appointment of
eight hectares of employment space
and approximately 130 dwellings as well
as a formation of an east-west alliance
vehicle of things
there are some site-specific
development principles including the
policy including strategic landscaping
area of green infrastructure
integration transfer connections
neighboring areas
appropriate design and noise mitigation
measures
it is noted that part of the commercial
element identification has already been
developed
by way of construction atlantic center
and recycling center
and as such following revised proposals
being submitted and negotiation with
your officers the proposal has now been
increased and would result in a total
amount of 6.62 hectares being provided
this is clearly less than the desired
amount of eight hectares as articulated
within the allocation policy
as well as the reduction in commercial
ad the proposed number of residential
units of 211
that exceeds numbers of units specified
within bid05 is to say approximately 130
dwellings
an initial housing mix has been put
forward which results in an over
provision of four and five bed units
when considered against the council's
housing and economic needs assessment
however this is an indicative mix
and a condition is recommended in the
officer's report to allow housing
mixtures considered at reserve matters
stage when detailed designs are
submitted which is the best
the best place to actually consider
those that housing rates
members will be aware of the lack of
five year housing supply and it's
considered that it is a conflict with
policy bid05
however there are clear benefits
associated with the proposal which meets
some of those quality aims
the decision maker needs in this case to
consider the mbps requirement to ground
permission unless any adverse impacts of
doing so would significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits of
so-called tilted balance
i'll return to this matter later on my
presentation
in terms of laptop balance at the end
moving on to design and impact on
landscape character
the application is made in outline with
only access to determination um
therefore as i've stated matters of
layout scale external appearance and
landscaping will be for that later
consideration
notwithstanding this the application is
supported by an illustrative master plan
which seeks to demonstrate that an
acceptable layout can be achieved at
detail stage
where 211 dwellings to come forward this
would represent a density of around 29
dwellings per hectare
this is considered appropriate for an
allocated site
and with reference to the prevailing
character of the area and the
surrounding residential in this area
in this indicative master plan proposes
commercial development to the north
adjoining the existing industrial state
in order to limit the perceived visual
impact of this element within the wider
views to the south with two larger
pockets of residential will be into the
east and the west
the landscape visual appraisal which
accompanies the application considers
likely effects on landscape character
and visual amenity
as expected given the change of the site
from greenfield to residential a
moderate level of effect is anticipated
with regard to site itself
and in terms of the wider landscape
character a moderate minor level effect
is expected
with respect to the effects on visual
amenity
effects on road users are found to be
limited to minor road routes as
demonstrated in the photographs to the
sound
and generally only available where gaps
occur in well-maintained roadside
development hedge funds
and the only real exception of this is
being cleveland road of course where the
roundabout will be a significant impact
to that visual character valley world
the application was an outline promotes
a clear design vision
inevitably the character of the locality
will change from open green fields to
mixed development including both
commercial and housing development
a balance has to be struck between
achieving the howdy numbers needed to
meet the five-year land supply
meeting the requirement for commercial
development
and also minimizing the visual impact on
the landscape
a certain density is required for
effective use of land
which in itself is a scarce resource
uh further assessment of the impact of
the precise scale massing and design of
the new dwellings will be undertaken at
reserve master stage
moving on to the impact on residential
communities
dwellings along the valley road
are the closest dwellings to the
proposal
as well as janet's cottage to the south
of the site
whilst it has not considered that to be
a significant impact on the immunities
of residential dwellings
the means of the existing residential
planning should i say
the immunities of the intended occupiers
of dwellings on the development also
need to be considered
the environmental protection officer has
considered the proposal with particular
attention directed to the relationship
between existing and proposed commercial
buildings on the side
whilst in an outlying form the
environmental protection officer concurs
that noise simulation measures are
available that can be introduced in
development and should
prevent significant adverse impact from
noise
and the imposition of conditions have
been recommended as bernie officer
report
in terms of air quality an air quality
and elder assessment has been submitted
and this has identified two potential
neighboring sources
which are reported not being significant
given the separation distances it is
considered unlikely that there is an
adverse impact will arise
choose potential potential impacts on
surrounding area construction a
construction environment management plan
is required and that is of its condition
um
and at the southland stage is not
considered like close event resulted in
a harmful impact on residential
amenities
of existing neighborhood occupiers
given the proximity of those negative
guys and typically on the side
moving on to accessing the highways
the main vehicle access point as we have
seen um is from a roundabout from valley
road to of the site with a commercial
element being accessed by a farm road
which is existing road by castle
industrial state
and via the atlantic record center
the proposed roundabout is a significant
element of highway infrastructure
which seeks to provide the required safe
safe access to the site
whilst the layout is currently
indicative
due to the outline nature of the
application pedestrian and cycling
facilities are provided throughout the
site
and it is noticed that site is in a
sustainable location with many
facilities within walking distances
following initial objections raised by
devon county council as highway
authority whatever discussions have
taken place in terms of roundabout
design and the stage one road safety
audit has been submitted
the highway authority now considers the
human rights side and capacity analysis
including consideration of seasonal
variation is acceptable
and shows that the proposed access will
operate acceptably in the future without
severe impact
video 5 as i mentioned earlier it
requires that an integrated highway
network is
provided
and also the formation of an east-west
vehicle link as part of a wider
distributor road
from the adjacent allocator site
and this is also provided within the
indicative layout and as a protected via
condition again in your office's report
the site is bounded to the west by a
unclassified county road uh scratch
based lane which is unsuitable for
domestic or commercial vehicle use
and it should be retained for pedestrian
of road recycle use
the proposal does not seek to utilize um
this route for any vehicle use aside
from a future link across the route to
the allocated development cycle of west
which again is required by the policy
the design and access statement
indicates that parking provision is
provided across the site in a variety of
forms predominantly on plot
however the exact parking provision will
be confirmed ab reserve battery stage
moving on to houses and archaeology
there are no list of buildings in the
site that is not located in the
constellation area
consideration of potentially impactful
steam on the adjacent bridges genetics
cottage and also a greater listed bridge
generation bridge
have been
considered which is located
approximately 30 meters to the south of
the site
the mass plan indicates that the land
within the southern part of the
application area comparison properties
is proposed for attenuation features and
public open space
the existing woodland along and beyond
southern southwestern boundaries on site
will also be retained
only limited intervisibility is
available
and which does limit that impact
the proposal subject to reserve matters
is unlikely to have any impact
on the aspect of setting that
contributes to the significance of the
greater
genus cottage or the listed bridge
or upon any key views that allow the
symptoms of these assets to be
appreciated
through anti-archaeology
development lies an area of
archaeological potential um our members
would be aware of a site visit that
there was evidence of
child pitch being dug and that was part
of a programme of intrusive field
evaluation that has been carried out
and the county archaeologist has
received the interim summary of these
results
the archaeologist has stated that whilst
the first development contains evidence
of prehistoric settlement the evidence
has been truncated by centuries of
agricultural activity
and naturally
of the
archaeological deposits investigated by
the field evaluation
do not appear to be of such
significance
that the archaeologists would advise
preservation in situ
moving on to drainage
as shown in the presentation um there
was a fledgling assessment and a
drainage strategy submitted the
application
the site lines were in flood zone one
and therefore there's a low probability
of flooding from pluvial and tiger
sources
the proposal seeks that discharge from
the site to be restricted to the green
field
based on the proposed incremental areas
and the fra has demonstrated the
proposal will not increase flood risk to
the site or the surrounding area
in terms of foul drainage
foul water is to be conveyed to a pump
station
located at the lowest point in the site
and from here pumped up the surface
waters filed cereal located at globally
road
uh southwest water have considered the
application and have confirmed that
there is sufficient capacity for the
proposed foul loads from 211 dwellings
and the employment
um devon county council as the local
flood authority had no intensive
objections uh providing conditions are
opposed to providing submission of
detail prior or as part of reserve
matters again that's a condition that's
on your
report
moving on to economy and trees
natural england has considered matters
including impact on designated sites
protect the landscape biodiversity
no objections have been raised subject
to mitigation measures
and agricultural impact assessment and
ecological impact assessment
and tree retention and removal plan a
company application
and whilst the application is an outline
the
agricultural impact assessment assesses
the impact on a tree stop from the
proposed development and demonstrate
which trees can be retained and which
can be removed
is noted um that there will be lots of
trees
um with two with layouts that's
addictive two um two trees being totally
lost
partial loss of a further thirteen items
which is to be mitigated with new
planting to ensure succession of the
existing tree stock
and new planting has potential for
longevity within the landscape and
enhance the species diversity to the
site
in terms of delivery or biodiversity net
gain the the net gain assessment
identifies that there will be a loss of
11.57 in terms of habitats
a gain of 10 in terms of hedgerow
and again 12.93 in terms of rivers
in order to deliver the 10
identity net gain required by a policy
off-site habitat creation is proposed
given the potential 11
loss in habitats
units
and this will be undertaking a strategic
location in concession the north dakota
biosphere reserve manager
the upsetting is considered consistent
with requirements of dm08
and has been agreed with natural england
who raised no concern
in terms of green infrastructure
agreements plan has been submitted as
shown in the presentation
and it shows how the various typologies
of bible policy can be met and provided
on site
this does show a significant
overprovision of immunity in natural
green space
blue has noted that it's calculated to
include the attenuation features of some
1.33 hectares
location of the various psychologies are
well distributed throughout the site
given by given the outline nature of the
site is recommended that provisions
require typologies and future
maintenance arrangements will be secured
by a section 106 agreement
almost there members
uh just moving on to viability and
section 106
um the proposal will secure a
comprehensive number of section 106
finance financial obligations as
detailed in your committee report of
over 1.2 million pounds
including contribution contribution to
education which includes send primary
early years and lab provision
nhs ccg
and library service
all the figures for that are provided
within your committee of course
the applicant has submitted a viability
appraisal that demonstrates that with a
policy compliant level contributions the
development will be unviable
the district valuation officer has been
instructed
by the district council to independently
verify the submitted viability
information
and the assigned db officer have
provided a written report to the council
which is appended to your committee
report
the tv officer concurs with the action's
contention that the ems proposed cannot
provide um
a plus compliant amount of the
section 16 computations
however he also concludes that the
scheme can provide more affordable
housing than originally put forward
foreign negotiations the applicant has
agreed to the additionality of the
affordable housing which then results in
13 units of on-site affordable housing
being viable
or being provided
as opposed to previously before 11.
and that's together with all of the all
other section 106 confusions
so section 106 package will include all
financial contributions um stated
as well as 13 units of on-site
affordable policy
vision percentage stands just over six
percent
the tv officer further recommends that a
section one section agreement uh
includes a provision of a viability
review um and this is something that
your officers recommend as well and the
app has accepted the conclusions of the
district valuer
agreed to be increasing affordable
housing um together with all of us
contributions
it is disappointing to officers that due
to viability issues a proposal is unable
to achieve a quality compliance number
affordable dwellings
or the desired balance of commercial
land and housing
however given the independently assessed
liability position and the additional
infrastructure that disposal will be
providing
which is including but not restricted to
the new spine road
roundabout junction and service
commercial land the section 106 package
is accepted by your officers
finally moving on to the planning
balance
um as stated we can we can't currently
demonstrate a five-year supply of
housing lands
that meets in these districts
as such there's a need to find a
consumption in favor of sustainable
development as a material consideration
and determining planning applications
the decision takers will therefore need
to consider the mpps requirement to
ground planning permission unless any
adverse impacts of doing so would
significantly and democratically
outweigh the benefits
[Music]
i know members are well versed in the
tools balance
now
the balance delivered benefits of the
proposal against the adverse impacts are
carefully detailed within your office's
committee report
the proposal does however depart from
the housing commercial labor balance
stipulated within policy video five
and this is considered within that wider
plan management planning balance as laid
down as your board
your officers are also disappointed that
the balance between housing commercial
ads does not meet the required policy
bid 05
and as i stated the housing provision
the high affordable housing provision is
below that extensive however in weighing
that identified harm against the
benefits
it's considered that the adverse impacts
associated with the development failed
to significantly and demonstrably
outweigh those benefits
the results being when assessed against
the policies in the north korean title
plan as a whole and the mppf
and having considered all the planning
issues and the material considerations
on balance a recommendation for approval
was made subject to the conditions laid
out in your office's report
and a section 106 being entered into
again header terms as detailed in your
committee report
that concludes my presentation just so
that members are aware we do have some
um officers with us today pete mcgrogan
from the evaluation office
if members have any questions about the
viability
uh matt collins from democratic castle
um highways
and also chris fuller from charleston
council on the economic development
perspective
thank you members
thank you sean for that long
and very comprehensive
presentation of that application
should give you time to get your breath
back in the room
have a drink because
our first speak or contribution
uh against the application is a letter
which used to be read out by
our family manager so
christopher young against the center
lettering which sean will reader
thank you
um so this is a representation or a
statement uh supplied by christopher
young
of 28 oakland's
billy food
my property in oakland has a boundary of
cleveland road my western fence on the
wooden side is shown on the new
roundabout drawing with a north point on
it
the position of the new roundabout is
one that affects my property as the
valley road begins to move to the right
in line with my fence which is shown in
the design plan
here
we need a noise assessment yeah i think
this microphone keeps
[Music]
yes
i'll start again members
my property in oakland's has a boundary
of developing earth my western fence on
the wooden side is shown on the new
round back room with a north point on it
the position on the new round back is
one that affects my property as the
valley road begins to move to the right
in line with my fence which is shown on
the design plan
this is a major difference like shown on
the consultation plan
the removal of more of the historic
strictly hedged on the south side
concerns me as that presently shields us
from the howling's warehouse and i hope
all of the hedge fund houdini's will
remain
i understand the new cycle footpath on
the southern side will still be behind
the hedge by the existing footpath on
our north side of the valley road will
continue
on our side of the road and i expect on
the cast downside too there is
considerable wildlife the woods and
indeed my garden trees provide a home
for at least 10 species of bats
most garden birds can also be seen and
the pond in the council owned woodland
has more hen an occasional kingfisher
barter have also been spotted coming up
the stream to the pond from torridge and
wooden floor provides a home for
if the new layout is adopted i hope that
the disused section of existing
carriageway as shown in the plan will be
planted which in turn will reduce extra
noise
i do not believe cleveland road imparts
the least historical purpose with
increased traffic being an old turnpike
although there is a wide foot cycle with
a footpath cycleway
after waterpark road further on asda
bnm and adams courts have all built in a
way that limits the possibility of
future road widening
towards the town too the road narrows
with some ineffective traffic calming
there is or will be at least eight
junctions between atlanta village and
water park road where at water park road
i believe it is essential that a mini
round about to be constructed not least
because it is a bus route number 75 that
turns right at that point onto cleveland
road and further visibility looking west
towards its poor religious development
traffic will increase
i have read the accompanying
documentation and making following
comments that relate to my area using
the numbering on documents
the framework travel plan
the walk to town does have a
topographical changes averaged about 80
meters of cast down to five meters in
50k
with really food fields on the hill the
walk-up is quite steep and cycling will
stand bicycle upwards which will fittest
thus there is no road space for a cycle
way until mortal part road
there will also be a sleek lift from the
bottom at buckingham roads to valley
road at present
via scratchy base lane
the nearby location little audi and asda
means that short top up food trips can
be undertaken by walking but the
shortest route past the tennis centre
and that scratchy face lane would still
be an uphill struggle for some
the weekend shop however will normally
need a car
all three food shops are at the highest
level about 90 meters and reaching them
from the area but near button road 50 to
60 meters will be difficult for a
standard bicycle
the wide end of the way between water
bottle and asda is a joint pedestrian
cycle route but although signed is not
separated with line markings on the
ground
low level trees discourage cyclists who
often use the main cavalli road
carriageway
the bus stop to the wester farm road is
used mainly for lighting as the 75 bus
turn terminator affinity atlantic
village
historic environmental assessment june
2020
sight the house is now now owned by a
family we're restoring it as a wedding
and holiday venue
reservoir the site is owned by us and
our neighbor the reservoir tank was
broken up in 1988 before that is served
walton house until direct remains
delayed
the reservoir was served by a pipe from
bathroom road reservoir across castle
water was then packed in modern house
the stream from the pond was modified by
water's livestock
troughs at winter farm until direct
remains
were laid
the water course itself flows to the
pill and eventually torridge the piper
cross cast out may still be present
well
the well shown on earlier plans in the
hedge lined up with the ditch leads from
the northern wooden side of cleveland
road
some maps mark issues at this spot
most water is groundwater from rain
through a pine mart and the savage water
map laid i believe with road changes for
1980s
but it's then an open stream from the
footpath of the pond
in calm dry weather there's still a
small flow and the water is crystal
clear
i was informed there was a spring in the
hedge at about 76 on the south side this
could be a small source of water that
flows to the torridge recently heavy
rain whale spring has been flowing on
occasions across the road at this point
i have nothing further to add thank you
christopher young
thank you sean um
next contribution is in support of it
and
jonathan check if he's here the agent
if he'd like to come forward and
use that microphone at the table left
if you tilt that microphone up and speak
right into the end of it please okay
okay
yeah that's fine and once you've settled
we've got three minutes to present to
the committee thank you thank you
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee
my name is jonathan chip from augustine
planning and i'm the agent representing
biddeford lba llp
in respect to this application
we welcome that the application is
recommended for approval
fundamentally this application is about
the delivery of new employment homes and
infrastructure
and also delivering the long-term names
and objectives of your council
in particular new employment in business
is a significant priority
this is not an opportunistic or
speculative application
but one that has been brought forward
carefully within a planned system
as you will be aware the site falls
within an allocation in the adopted
local plan
for employment and residential
development
there are significant enabling costs
associated with this development due to
the quantum employment plans
that are not associated with standalone
residential developments
it has not been possible to achieve the
exact balance of employment and
residential land within the allocation
it has still been possible to include a
substantial amount of employment plans
taking the overall quantum included in
the allocation to 6.62 hectares
the residential element of the scheme is
what will enable new employment land to
come forward
therefore this is not a loss of
employment land from the allocation but
a means to bring the employment land
forward
without this application there would be
no employment land coming forward or
being made available
the employment land will make an
important contribution to the economic
needs of the area including significant
job creation for residents and
surrounding communities
the additional homes provided will make
significant contribution to the
council's housing land supply which is
currently below 5 years
the proposals also include new
infrastructure and community benefits
including a new spying road footpaths
drainage public open space
10 biodiversity net gain
and the full package of section 106
obligations without compromising the
viability
the application is a result of extensive
pre-application consultation
we have worked closely with the
council's planning and economic
development teams over the past three
years
and there have been a number of
revisions to the master plan to ensure
delivery of as much employment land as
possible
following submission of the application
the applicant has worked closely with
the council to address any issues raised
and as a result there are no objections
from any statutory quantities
we note the concerns raised by the local
objective but these are all matters
which have been addressed in the
committee report and through the course
of the application
we'd like to thank courage officers and
other stakeholders for their efforts in
getting our client sites to positions
now
i'm grateful for your time and ask you
to support today's recommendation
thank you
thank you mr chip thank you
and finally to speak councillor brenton
board member
for this site comes from
uh good morning fellow councillors good
morning ladies and gentlemen
as the
chairman indicated earlier on uh my time
is limitless it's not right
please no i'll try not to explain that
um basically my as you know the
comprehensive report which
uh
details which i'm not going to go
through but i really just want to point
out the housing element
and the affordable housing element that
is a bit that the town council majored
on
and i think it's one that we really
should consider most seriously
because
how many meetings have we had we're
ringing our hands saying what we need in
this area is affordable housing
and we're not getting it from this i
mean i know there'll be nice figures
presented to you about viability and how
this can be available in that campaign
come on this is a big scheme you're
talking about a 50 million pound scheme
here and you're telling me that they can
only come up after a bit of squeezing
with 13
houses
that's just not on you know we're not
stupid people we know jolly well that
these people do make big profits and
directors get fast salaries you know
that is the stake of play we're in and
there's no problem selling houses in
this area they're going up in value all
the time so there's that that doesn't
come into the equation either
so i ask you to look at this report
carefully
but in in particular
for example on page 17 the health and
well-being element which is
from the county council
you know the same and how desperately
urgent it is that we get uh decent
housing for our local population many of
whom will never ever be able to afford a
mortgage
we're short of care staff now my
daughter's a nurse in the local hospital
and they can't recruit people the nurses
because they can't come down and afford
the housing care it's just so we're
going to be stuck with uh
with
a shortage of skilled people
now back in the day when i first
actually moved
from across the water
in north devon
we used to have things like um
key worker housing
that hasn't been seen for decades
but we had it here because it we needed
it to get people into the area that were
vital to our economy or our our social
infrastructure
so these i think are things you consider
and i think on that basis you should
really seriously consider turning this
application down and handing it back to
and say come on come up with some
realistic figures for affordable housing
for our population and i'll just make
sure on that point leave it there thank
you very much
thank you councillor brent
[Music]
right that's the end of the
contributions
to this application of republican from
council brenton
we would like to start the discussion on
this application
well count councillor document counselor
christian
um
parts of the report is on page 29 and 30
from the regeneration officer i mean he
states he is disappointed with the loss
of attention
but then he further states although a
long way from a perfect scenario now how
many times in life let alone planning
considerations didn't get perfect
scenarios and he does go on to say
um
that this is a positive opportunity to
bring forward much employ their
advertising so we should be supportive
so i entirely agree with that comment
and i think that is important
i've completely taken all what council
brendan's just said about the form of
the ball
um and it's only gonna be 13
and i did
chuckle to myself on page 24 when it
says affordable housing that it should
be pepper potted around the estate we've
never really made it blocks i don't
quite know about 13 we're going to be
peppa around the estate
um
so i'll stop there for the time being
i've got one or two other matters but
regeneration is important okay okay
thank you council councillor christie
thank you yes um
well my heart sank when i got the 247
page agenda
um just before christmas i have read
every line of it
um and with this application the one
thing that i have to point out this is
outline and we need to get it right at
this stage
uh to my mind there are four issues uh
the loss of industrial land that council
lock has just referred to
um it was going to be 130 houses with
eight hectares of employment land it's
now 211 houses with 6.62 hectares i
think it's a new figure
um
mention has been made of our economic
regeneration officer who i noticed
opposed this to start with and then i
don't want to put words in his mouth but
it's pretty obvious from our report it
was pretty grudgingly
he supported it
um
what intrigued me was the claims that
somehow the tennis center and the
recycling
made up the remnant of the employment
land
we've had the tennis centre come along
they employ virtually nobody because
they keep telling us it's all volunteers
they think well that's not really
employment land is it and the recycling
center is well i find what six people
um and i find a bit odd that they're
trying to somehow say that's you know
huge employment land
um as to the
agents saying oh one go ahead i noticed
the profit margin in the plan for
commercial land is 15
you know that's not bad uh if you've had
your latest interest
was it 0.01
but 15 isn't bad
and the second issue that uh councilman
brenton has already touched on
affordable homes five percent is the
risery
um especially when they do make a profit
six percent has against 17 and a half
percent on freight on open market houses
and i noticed that even the district
valuer did agree with the viability
study
and uh did manage to up it slightly
um
but i did go through the viability study
i'm intrigued by them and i noticed yet
again there's a million pounds for
marketing
all you do is put them on the internet
and they sell in two days a million
pounds for marketing that's ridiculous
um also
on page 39 we're told that the viability
study
is based on the house sizes
and yet our planning officer just told
us that planning sizes won't be decided
until
it's a full application this is chicken
and egg the viability study is based on
one set of figures
that's the ones we've got before us and
yet i'm now told that
that those figures won't be correct i
don't think well how can we take the
viability study at face value
and the third point is uh house sizes
now a quarter of the houses that are
proposed are four bedrooms i was in
treatment our planning officers said
four and five bedrooms there are no five
bedrooms born to the developer i'm not
sure where that comes from but a quarter
of them are four bedrooms yeah our own
policy stakes only fifteen percent
should be four bedroom and yet again
this goat feeds into the viability study
and the last point
and this is the elephant in the room
nobody has mentioned it once
and yet it is the most vital issue
the school
school provision
now we are aware that um
according to this 1.3 million is being
claimed by devon county for education
1.3 million but where is the new school
we were told when winsford
across the road behind the trinity
center or whatever it's called now
uh
the developers there cannot build their
750 houses until they build the school
because of the hugely pressing need for
educational provision and benefits
we are then told that the developer of
winsford will not sign the section 106
for the school
so where is the school going to go
because if you take this site and the
one next door which has already got
outlined there are
485 houses being proposed
those houses could be built with no
school provided
and my mind goes back to londonderry
when londonderry was proposed there was
going to be a new store
is there a new school no
we are constantly
upgraded by the public
but not supplying infrastructure whether
it be doctor surgeries whatever
schools
i read again in this 1.3 million is
going to a school but there is no school
where is it going to go we cannot pass
this
when we haven't addressed that issue and
rather than councillor brenton saying
turn it down i propose we defer it
until we sort this out because otherwise
we leave ourselves open to a complete
chaos in the education system in benefit
thank you
thank you council christian sean of
uniform
i strongly agree apparently christian
side will second
his proposal furthest
to come back we actually
consolidated evidence you know the
school issue is paramount
in the local area so yeah this slipping
under the under the carpet isn't good
enough so
i fully endorse cancer christine all
right just
um i'm planning a management comment
thank you members can hear me
yeah okay so just picking up on some of
those some of those matters
in terms of the housing mix and the
viability um
clearly we need to have a starting point
without violence assessment
if we were to do that viability
assessment on a housing mix
which included less number
bed dwellings then clearly that
vibration position would be worse than
what's in this and would be achieving
less numbers or housing
use the term chicken leg and i think
you're quite right because we do want to
look at the housing mix at reserve
matters because that's the appropriate
time to do so we're looking at layout
etc
but for the purposes of the viability
this is actually the best case scenario
for us to look at those um that amount
because if it was smaller dwellings the
profit is likely to be reduced and again
the district value is here and we have a
good comment further on that
in relation to this school
now
um council christie mentioned 1.2 1.3
million that's not the amount for the
support from this site um that's a total
bang that's a total financial package um
i think it was something
uh 887 000 is the actual
primary school amount
this allocation doesn't include an
element for school it never has done so
the school wouldn't be provided here
however the school site is on the
adjacent bid09 which has got outline
planning permission and is subject to
reserve matters application at the
moment which will no doubt come in front
of the committee in due course which
does show a school site for this school
the officers have confidence that school
will come forward and we've been
negotiating with democratic council and
members will be aware of gaddon for
example where school's going for their
dad and now um
again you could say chicken there
because they do need that money for that
school to come forward but there is a
site on the adjacent
allocation and that is where the site
was always allocated there's never a hit
on this site
um so i'm not clear how or i'm not clear
what the
reason for deferring application would
be on that as this application site and
the allocation never referred to school
but it does contribute a financial
amount to a school on the adjacent side
which has outlined planning permission
thank you sean
perhaps you could just confirm
or clarify for me the rest of the
committee
and everybody watching and listening
i always understood what the site next
on winston site there was going to be a
school
on there
but where are we with it actually being
built
you know it's all right allocating the
site and the data
the davin hill is one in case in point
we know there's a site going to be
provided on there for a school
but how do we actually get the school
built
yeah clearly supplies of schools and
delirious school is a county council
matter
however like i say the first stage is to
get planning permission for that site
an adjacent site has got outline
performance already and reserve matters
is with us which does indicate a cyclist
school
and that's the nine site uh winsford
which is a different site that's north
of cleveland road that also has um
provisions for a school site um
i wouldn't want to speak for devon
county council but i imagine it would be
one or the other and as it still happens
bid09 which is adjacent cyclist is the
one that has already got outline plan
permission and there is a reserved
matters application with us at the
moment which is valid which obviously
we're looking at when i say we'll be
coming to numbers and due course which
shows that school side
thank you um
i'll bring the council watson in there
and then cancel christy
yeah um
sean
told us that
106 um is 1.2 million
does this include the education money
for education then
that's all in that is it
right okay
and and
we talk about schools
um kevin county don't build schools
you know i don't know whether they put
an application in
uh for a school to be built but they
don't build schools as told to us by
john r the leader
to make it clear but who is going to do
this then and bring us and build a
school but on the allocated spot
and because i'm not sure where when it
will ever get schooled
i've never been well i've been on this
committee i've never known devon county
build anything but
um
but yeah i
i'm off off thinking about going with
peter
watson just to confirm regard to the
financial contributions section 106 will
provide and says decent confusion
so in terms of education maybe 98 140 in
relation to
special needs send provision
887
838 in relation to the primary school
which we're discussing collision
um
[Music]
81 669 in terms of land provision
that's acquisition cost
52 750 in terms of early years education
twenty two thousand two hundred and
sixty depends in relation to the library
service
hundred and ten thousand four hundred
ninety three in relation to mh the nhs
requested and it is determining
committee reports
um
sure
how much money do we have to give
to highways then to do the
roundabout
um where's that money from
yeah matt collins may want to um discuss
that but that would look like it's part
of this development um right we'll bring
that into that second what i would also
like to say to members um discussion
about the school
we need to determine this application on
the basis of this application
and this application is bringing forward
the education contribution requested by
democratic council and it's meeting that
so it's meeting that infrastructure
needs
there is no
material reason for this application to
deliver a school on this site
um it will contribute to a school
and that has been dealt with by that
figure for the session 106 obligation as
we've requested
so i have significant concerns
to exploring that further obviously
that's remember to consider
members may want to speak to macmillan
about the delivery of the roundabouts
on that
basis you sean
councillor christian yes i just wanted
to come back on the school because
um i'm a bit surprised to hear dad moore
brought up i mean that morning miles
from this site and there's no way
children are going to walk up to dad and
water um
i'll go back to this one because when we
passed the outline planning mission for
site next door
the school site was provisional
it was only there on the basis that
winswood didn't come forward
and yet i'm now told winston hasn't come
forward and yet there's going to be a
school there
that doesn't sit well with me because
that's not it's not absolutely correct
is it nothing has been tied down nothing
has been signed off it's already saying
this site provides the money but where
does the money go
um i mean if that school isn't built
within what is it five years the section
106 go back to the
developers and yet we're not
we don't seem to be uh
fulfilling our duty of counsellors of
making sure everything is in place
because as i said the school to me is
the big elephant in the room it's the
most important thing
really
well
as a planning manager said either the
winston site would have a school site
provided or middle live in next door
we have a school site but not on this
site that we're discussing this morning
there's no provision to have a sample
school on here but they are making this
contribution
towards a school of 887
and the roundabouts in the
district values assessment of the
viability appraisal
speaks of um starting company
allowing 345 000
for the roundabout but the district
value i've seen
215 000 pounds in so
these all add up
certain company they all add up to 7
million this is on page 72
but district value adds it up to just
under 6 million
yeah thanks very much um
i still support uh council christie for
the referral because the affordability
is a bit of a smaller which i'm not
going to be spoiling to be honest i
think this this country should stand
forever 30
and if that means it'll let us go go
back to the figures they're going to
sweep the figures
within this area the affordable housing
we all know
we're pushing something uphill
and not being very good with it um loss
of commercial industrial land we need it
we need commercial industry now that's
how we get going through the area we
haven't got it we're not supplying it
this development is not supplying the
commercial and industrial use that we
need
so we would build all commercial
or industrial use
or we just go residential
i don't think we can get the next it
just doesn't go together because the mix
of
the residential with commercial real
news is going
[Music]
unfortunate situation with a
i think the fifth generation of dairy
farmers
will be long for that business is closed
once the betterment starts going through
you're pushing out the employment you
know the same big appointment let's see
what important is bringing into the area
it's bringing lovely employment for the
developer
to use your own local trades coming
through so i the firmware's going to be
done in my again mr chairman and it's
the affordability side of things i'd
like to see improved because i don't
think i don't agree with 13 footage
well as far as
the mix of
business use and dwelling you can do it
properly
you can mix the two and in fact
um
it's policy now throughout the country
where you've got to have housing near
employment uses but it's how it's done
that matters
um
thank you
i'd just like to ask about the
commercial industrial land we know
there's a shortage because we tried to
you know purchase land for
our own environment center
so if we lose some of the commercial and
industrial land here where on earth are
we going to put it
because we definitely need it because
truly we've assessed how much we need
and that's how much we need that's why
it's in the plan
where else is it going to go
well it's not for discussion today but
over at the winston site there's a
mixture there of
residential and business use so
we're not completely devoid this isn't
the only area
that we can have business development on
in the district so there are other sites
around
but we've got to stick with what we're
looking at this morning and the thing
about deferring this application is
really we've got the evidence we've had
step and companies
uh viability appraisal down and then
we've done it we've had the district
value go through it all and i mean i'm
completely in agreement i agree with
councillor brent
on the fact that we're not provided the
amount of affordable that we would like
to see
but we're between a rock and a half
places a lot of these applications
because these viability appraisals are
done
um
they tweet they're adjusted there's a
lot of guests working well but it is
guest reports supposition because as far
as
the housing provision
like councillor christie mentioned it
there are no five bedrooms
but
26 i think it is we're down as four
bedroom countries
so
the viability has been worked on that
now
if that's changed and there are more for
bed or there are five bed eventually at
the reserve matters change
that viability appraisal changes again
in my view
and i did make a note in here looking
through all this
that the section 106 which i don't think
inside yet
the section 106 but it should include a
viability review
because whenever this is built and we
all hope it would be built as fast as
residential
sooner rather than later
um
and house prices are available all the
time tremendous amount over the last 12
months there's talk of maybe an
adjustment downward but i
certainly can't see it at the moment
because it's such a shortage of housing
so
we ought to have in the 106 definitely a
viability review
after a certain
percentage of the houses have been
built and marketed because
over time these houses could provide far
more money
they found more profitable than is in
the viability prison that is one of the
big problems we've got with these
liability appraisals
they are causing awful problems for us
but i don't think to defer it
there's no point in deferring it
because we're not going to be any
further forward if you defer this
we know there's no school site on here
so we can't defer it and decide we want
a school site on here
because there's one
proposed on the site next door
or at winston
so it's nice to defer it to try and get
any kind of clarity on provision of the
school site because not it's not part of
the application i bring cancer locking
down then
we completely agree with the chair i
don't see how we can possibly defer it
um
because a school site does not part of
this application
um and going back to
councilman goff's um lack of
vulnerability i had two operations
but
i cannot remember one application where
we have got the 30 before
every single plan an application seems
to get around their viability
assessments and i still can't understand
this is directed to sure
why we couldn't have a condition now on
the outline application that a viability
review mechanism condition is set rather
than weight to the section 106.
why can't it go on an outline
application
such a condition wouldn't be the tester
condition and the section 106 is the
appropriate mechanism which is totally
enforceable um
so yeah as part the current mission
wouldn't be granted until section 1 6
was signed and there would be an element
in that section one sixth requiring this
review mechanism um which is something
that we started to do as members will be
aware of previous applications but the
section 106 is the appropriate place for
that review mechanism it'll still be
totally enforceable
just one more point chair and i was
pleased to see on page 34 a detailed
response in the nhs i don't think we use
this in such detail um
responses and that there is a section
money but we all know as well
in schools that we can't make doctors
build their new surgeries today our
private companies of business so we
can't say that we must build or enlarge
your surgery
um so i've carefully considered this
application i have read through
in great detail for people and the
viability report and i note that there
are no status quo teams have any
[Music]
thank you
we have we do have a proposal currently
to defer uh bring councillor chris about
you
i will go back on school but just before
that i will follow up councillor
about the viability studies
the easiest way around it is in our new
district plan
we make the rule that the land owner who
stands to make a huge amount of money
will pay for a viability study before
any land is included in our district
plan if it can't be for 30 it doesn't
get included full stop there's only one
i mean i've
i've sympathy with that there's only one
problem with that the landowner would
not know all the contributions that were
going to be asked on that site
when an application comes forward like
the education contribution health
contributions highways contributions a
landlord wouldn't know but at the
initial state how much
is going to be asked in the future is
that be difficult to do a viability
without knowing those those things i
mean in here and there's need to see
which i'm always very skeptical of is in
biodiversity offset business that seems
to be being used an awful lot these days
there's
thousand
176
here over this side of audio
biodiversity offset
we never do see what these schemes are
we give it to the north gaming biosphere
for their schemes dotted wherever they
are we never see them anymore but that
does not benefit the local area so this
biodiversity offset
again is another big cost i'm giving 70
cents
to the development but
yeah counter christian yeah it's going
to come back in schools
i was amazed that biodiversity as with
you because it's the last time i
remember one day
it was going to be in my ward it was the
first time i've heard of it uh i don't
know from the god remembers that we were
astonished what what's this all about
anyway
um to the schools i'm sorry but
we're in a situation now where
we were going to get schooled at the
windsor apparently they're not going to
sign the section 106 i have no idea
what's happening there so there is going
to be no school there at the moment
our backup plan is the site next door
but that was only provisional
we've got nobody tanning svs there is
going to be a school here and on this
site now we've been told i was going to
give i make it 1.18 million
1.3 now but even so where's that money
going if there's no school and i i'm
afraid i cannot sit here
and just vote through another scheme
that could see 211 houses built on this
site with no school
for
the kids who live here because that
could happen if we don't sort it out
that's why i want to defer so we can try
and sort out the school issue i don't
understand why the one at winston isn't
going ahead because we voted it through
on that basis
why isn't the developer going to build
it or at least provide the land
thank you council christie um and i
appreciate your passions very important
subjects
um
it does however
it's another reason that this matter
this discussion isn't necessarily
directly related to the material
planning situations of this particular
application
in terms of the education authority
leading on providing a school
there of course is an argument that we'd
have to give them the tools that
financial ability to do that and if we
weren't to do that as part of this
application
then a school may not come forward
anyway
as you've quite rightly said there was
two sites winsford the norfolk valley
road on this side
originally wintered i think would be
favored as it was considered to come
forward first
it hasn't which is why you have a
fallback site and
it appears that bit 09 is coming forward
um hence the reserve matters
applications you're only considering
this is that confidence
the reason i mentioned davin earlier on
wasn't in relation to potentially taking
up the requirement for
these new dwellings but it's just an
example of a new school coming forward
and we're in late discussions as
officers with devon county
about that school coming forward and
that's a good if we had this very
similar discussion about dad when the
dance that came up about whether school
would be delivered well that is going to
be delivered
and i'd hope it'd be same with this site
on adjacent this side bit 09
but that's not a material planning
solution with this application
this application dev county council have
requested this amount of money
and they have detailed within their
constitutional response which we will
see reports
the increase of students
of children quite not just from this
site but also other sites around and the
contribution required for that
and the place where that will be
delivered will be bitter night um in the
front of the time of course
and we are quite
a long way along with granted planning
commission for that site
subject to committed considerations as
it already has got outline permission we
have got reserve matters
so to consider that element as part of
this application i find difficult i
think there is a separate discussion to
be had and i know we have had a meeting
previously um committing members with
democratic council education and maybe
that we want to rearrange a further
meeting um in light of the potential
progression of dating and bid online
but i don't see that as being
particularly a consideration relevant
with this application
thank you
council christine sorry to labor this
but i'm really happy to hear that
discussions about a new school next door
are pretty advanced
and therefore i will maintain that we
defer it until they're signed off if
they're fully advanced it's going to be
very long
[Music]
um i said dad in schools for the
advanced uh valley events um in northern
this site is advanced in terms of
planning in that we've got reserve
masters application but not discussions
in relation to the school it's a
downside just to clarify that matter
right
um
as to some of the costs when we look at
the viabilities mentioned about the
marketing costs
on page 73 you'll note there that the
district valuer
did consider some of these rates to be
excessive
sterling company were looking for 3 of
gdv in respect of market housing and two
percent in respect to the commercial
element
the district value reduced in his
opinion
he considered the rates excessive so
you know it is assessed
the viability in prison is properly
assessed
and it's national criteria that they
used and again we we probably don't in
some respects agree with some of the
national criteria that are used but they
are
nationally accepted
criteria that are used during these
viabilities
as i mentioned a minute ago and the one
that we should be putting in the 106 is
the viability reviews because that's
crucial
whenever the properties that aren't
start to be unsolved if you sold for 10
to 15 20 30 000 more that was fought
during the viability pressure it could
be two or three years before
and
it would make a vast difference so
there is a chance
to claw back it's probably a very small
chance but this is a chance nonetheless
and and as sean has said we have started
to insert and all the developers don't
like this in sexual sexes but that's uh
that's a matter of
hard lines as far as they can say we
want them in i think
we more and more will expect to see
viability appraisals review
and signed up in section 106 and as sean
said they are then legally enforceable
and it does matter
and
but we do have issues i know
the first proposal there's no more
contributions
the first proposal was to develop
council christie proposer councilman
goff second that they
still want us to vote on that
so we'll vote on that first whether this
is deferred and i've got to say we
really haven't got any reason to defer
it but that was a proposal that's put
forward by council christian second in
my counselor
so could you take the vote on that thank
you chair council about him
that's the browns that's the christie or
councillor craigie or
castle leather against
councillor against
councillor mcgoff four
councillor watson against
wiseman
that's three four
and six against chad
thank you
so much then we go to the proposal from
council a lot to approve this scheme
secondly by councillor
you take the vote
so i can i just confirm um for my verbal
update the amendment to condition seven
um so it should state bit of nine and
supposed to be the same language
development
and also on the vote on this one to
approve is in the section one and six
agreement
against
councillor crazy against
councillor leather poor
councillor paul
councillor mcgoff yes
councillor watson oh
that's the wise men four
there's a meeting
our next application is 7b and that's on
pages
97 to 198
and tracy blackmore
give this presentation
thank you i just want to check you can
hear me
okay so this is application reference
number one
two
slash
slash twenty twenty slash btn
this is another major outline planning
application with all matters reserved
other than access
so this is for the erection of up to 290
dwellings
public open space sustainable urban
drainage systems between the attenuation
ponds and associated infrastructure at
lounge north of habitat road in
biddeford
next slide please
do just a couple of verbal updates
what's the officer's report
there has been one further
representation received since the
publication of this report
um this goes into the matter of the
ecology conditions which is set out in
the agenda specifying the employment of
an ecologist to ensure the delivery of
the required ecological litigation
measures
so the representation goes on to say
whilst they welcome this in principle it
is incumbent upon the lpa to recognise
they have an ongoing responsibility to
safeguard the environment
um the lpa must by continuing to use
truly independent ecologists
um those oncologist
to maintain careful scrutiny of all
aspects of development likely to impinge
on oncology
um so i think this has been addressed
obviously the ecology conditions set out
um the wording does include the
appointment of an oncologist to manage
your psychology works and his plans for
independent colleges to further
reviewing the future massive application
so i think you know just because we have
used an independent product
we would continue those works from which
matters to actually being in development
on site
there is also one type though um in
regards to condition five r so that
should be
identification design areas generally
our build form densities and design
principles i think that condition
actually makes for stable um which there
is no saying
so okay so going on to the presentation
so just before i
kick off just to advise members i have
invited a number of technical
consultants to today's plans committee
and i'd first like to thank them for
further attending today and for their
work on this application
so the technical quantities present for
members to ask questions of include
sarah jennings
an ecologist who hasn't reviewed the
ecology aspect of this application
helen henry a flood increased
engineer from denver county council
mike newcomb from the highway authority
and
mcguigan from the district evaluation
officer
they are here and they are ready to
answer any technical questions you have
um on the application so please feel
free to use those technical constanties
so moving on to the presentation
say this is obviously the location plan
of the site outlined in red and blue
as a whole the site is approximately
18.87 hectares in size and comprises of
three agricultural fields and the second
half of the fourth agricultural
field just to feminise members of the
branches of the site members have uh
attended a comprehensive site virtual
site visit and will be creating the site
boundaries
um to the south of the site is abduction
road to the east is osborne lane which
is a very narrow country lane
and the site borders to the north north
down road
um and as i'm sure it's like this um
members can remember there was video
clips of me driving down those
boundaries support the site
the site is banned into the west by the
a39 and the a39
viaduct
a single dwelling is located to the
south east corner of the site which
encompasses the whole site
um and the southwest corner of the site
there are a number of weddings known as
lower winston court
save the next slide
sorry this is another
planned with the satellite sites
outlined in red
it demonstrates the relationship of the
site which sits to the east of the built
form of biddeford and again shows the
road boundaries of the site annotation
plan
next slide
this is a site context plan which again
demonstrates the site outlined in red
with abbott road indicated in blue to
the southern boundary of the site the
a39 to the western boundary
and as you can see from the image the
site is a little easier to use a bit of
the built form it needs it lies
immediately to the west of the london
gray farm state
um with osborne lane dividing those two
sites
next slide
see this is just an aerial image the
site's outlined again in red
there is a central area woodland called
badgersfieldwood
which has a wooden tpo on it and there
are also watercourses running through
the site which runs southwards into
camera valley
um as you can see there is also these
predominantly agricultural lands with
mature hedge foundries and sheer trees
so next slide
so just to provide members with a
strategic context this is an extract
from the north government original plan
and policies map or wildfire
the site is the west of the town being
indicated with an orange arrow so this
is to remind members how the site fits
in with the context of the strategic
center of billford
so the next slide is just slightly more
focused in on the site from out of the
extract map
again the orange line represents our
site and you'll see the black line which
is the development boundary for
biddeford as you can see um the
development is outside the development
boundary but the development boundary
joins the site to the south and east
so the south of the site is um b1 which
is the strategic urban extension of
approximately 71 hectares
so
just going sort of further into the
presentation i want to just remind
members of the proposal so while the
proposal has been submitted in outline
there has been an illustrated
development plan um framework which has
been submitted to demonstrate how the
scheme could be accommodated on site
so this this is from how how it could be
developed it is illustrative you know
he isn't part of determination for today
so as i said this is a major planning
application of all matters reserved
other than access for up to 290
dwellings including 15 affordable
the housing offer 11.07 hectares of
important and poor open space
including unique subspecies including
four tenuration basements
access is the detailed consideration at
the stage and the proposal includes two
vehicle accesses points from average
road indicated in two red arrows
the hedge along the southern boundary is
proposed to be translocated should
provide a freely to shared footway cycle
rate along actually road frontage and
the widening of the footwear on the
northern side of action road between
possible lane
and landing field to two meters to
provide again connectivity in spillford
so i'm just going to run through some
photos um i know members attended a very
detailed virtual site visit so i'm going
to try and be quite brief or photos um
but i thought it was still important to
outline
um some of the photos of the site next
slide so this is the photo showing the
street level of aberration road members
will record a video frontier of the
boundary which you can travel around um
just to show that boundary and where the
two vehicle access points are to be
located on the site
and the proposal also includes
um the hedge to be translocated back
into the site to provide that three
metre footwear cycleway provision along
that road to provide that
so connectivity slide
so again it has been agreed for devon
county council that the existing 30 mile
an hour zone on abortion road will be
extended to the west
this will result in the 30 mile an hour
and being extended to include the whole
frontage of the spikes along action road
say next slide
say this is a phase show at the top of
our bedroom road as members will recall
the proposal includes the potential
closure of osborne lane to be used
pedestrian cyclists
next slide
um so the proposal includes the widening
of this section of footwear to two
meters to the existing crossing again to
improve the connectivity and pedestrian
linkings to the site to build
a very comprehensive virtual video of
the site
um members remember this is a photo of
the sun boundary of the site so the
hedge to the right of that photo is
being translocated to form the vehicle
access
the next slide see this is the photo
slightly further back from the site
looking at the southern boundary
next slide
so this is a fake little middle site
this is taken to the southwest of the
boundary so the white building in the
distance is lower windsword court which
a number of waves and third party
ownership and the next slide is slightly
focused in
that boundary again showing the
dwellings though lowers linking the
court which is situated to the southwest
boundary of the site
and the phase also includes an element
of the western boundary like that hedge
row and behind the hedgerow lies the a39
so in the next slide so this photo is
taking a little western boundary the
site to the left this badges
kill wood which will be further explored
there are photos of trees within the
facial needs to be removed to
accommodate the road infrastructure
network into the site
so this photo is taken from the eastern
boundary the right way is there a risk
of cottage which indicates its own
access from osborne lane
the next slide shows the eastern
boundary of the site and the hedge bank
is the osmo name and as you can see the
eastern residential edge of biddeford
with existing dwellings on that london
tourist stage
another phase of the eastern boundary
and then my next slide shows where i am
in the northern boundary looking to the
southwestern side again showing that
built form
background
the next slide is the northern badge of
the site again and again the photo shows
water forces running through the site
the next slide to show the space is
looking south to badgersville wood which
is located in central site
and this photo is within
badgersvillewood
which is not worked by the woodlands
so during the course of the application
the majority of the woodland
has been agreed to be accessible by
public access
but this is to be managed there is a
proposed buffer area around the woodland
protection which we showed later on this
presentation
as members will report an independent
ecologist sarah james videos here today
has been called review the economy
matters and respect of this application
so another photo next slide or woodland
into the north
and another photo
again of woodland
so the next slide shows the western
section
there's another one of the western
section of the site
so this shows i think the sort of
undulating and sort of deeply designed
photography of the site and there is
quite a very trophy
the site
it also clearly shows the london jury
estate
so the next line shows the northwest
corner of the site and to the left you
can see the western boundary of the a39
and the e39 viaduct
another photo again showing the western
section showing an existing built form
and you'll just see the woodland in the
middle of
the site
and then another photo again um showing
the western section and the western
parcels of now has been developed
another photo again looking west um
showing the southern element of the
badges of the wood
and this is undertaken
next slide sorry another photo that just
shows the southern boundary the abbot
road where we started in terms of that
hedge bank is to be transported and
needed for the two access vehicle points
so a landscape visually impact
assessment and lvia has been submitted
which shows photo montages
so the next slide shows various
viewpoints surrounding the site
so the next few photos will show the
photo montages from the existing built
form of bitter food
so taken from the london green state to
the east
so the viewpoints are 23 24 25 26 and 20
so i don't see them very well the yellow
dots where the london should we stay off
that's where these next slides
have been taken from
so the next slide shows the top photo
taken from melbourne way which indicates
the site with a black arrow
and the bottom photo demonstrates to the
site from the open space to the eastern
south bridge park
the next side shows the top vote over
the open space to the
south the warren view and that's just
the glimpse of the a39 viaduct
and the bottom facials from the open
space northern quarry place
the next photo is from the green space
from jury estate and there are a number
of viewpoints and you can see the site
badges hillwood 39
and
the next slide
is again the top
photos you can space the west plain
enfield
isn't that visual from that viewpoint
and then the bottom photos are cited
from average
so the next series of phases shows the
lbia images from the north west site
so the next slide shows a viewpoint from
the site from within the grounds of
kevin castle
so looking to the northwest
the next side shows photo from the east
towards the site from the viaduct of
white house cross
the next photo shows looking south west
of the site from the lane east of the
a39 viaduct
and the next view is the
view of the site from the eastern side
from the edge of that ship
and the next side so um this is quite a
good slide so this is standing from the
north of the site from the public
football from first hill looking towards
the site
in terms of the submitted ldia submitted
in support of the applications members
will recall from my report this has been
reviewed by an independent landing
officer
the comments of the independent
landscape officer is set out in full um
in your report to ensure you have read
those
the conclusion comments of the
independent landscape officer
uh concludes that there is some
disagreement that the main conclusion
wasn't submitted lbia
and then the landscapers officers view
the proposal would result in a change
the landscape character of the site
this will be further explored in my
presentation
so the next slide
is a plan of the surrounding landscape
designations sorry this is a bit small
to see
so the site is annotated in red
in the middle the site is not itself
covered by any statutory or
non-statutory designations for landscape
or quality or character
so the north
meters to s east
and there's an orange hatchling to the
east
and also the aov longs along the west
side which again the orange hatch line
there are 17 listed buildings within the
study area which should have been
indicated on the planet as blue circles
the council's conservation officer has
been consulted with this application has
raised their objections
the county council senior historic
environment officer has also been
consulted and advised that there has
been previously archaeological field
evaluation that has demonstrated the
presence of some archaeological features
across the site
these features however are not such
significant that they should be
preserved in situ
the impact of the development however
should be mitigated by a program of
psychological works therefore a
pre-commencement condition has been
agreed to ensure
[Music]
drawings
so as we know
highways is the detail consideration
stage at outline
and mike newcomb is here for if you have
any highway questions
so this is again a technical highway
drawing showing the two new vehicle
access points from our russian road and
the three metre birds shared football
cycle way to allow the connecting team
to feel the good
so the next slide
again picked up
via version side visit shows the
widening of the footwear along the
northern side of action road um and then
field the two meters to the existing
crossing again to provide that better
connectivity
i just thought at this point i'm sorry
it is quite a long presentation but it
is quite a complex site i would just
like to go back to the framework just to
remind members
again how the site could potentially be
developed
next slide
so the beige areas are where this plate
um is being proposed for dwellings
and the prepaid sex features are marked
on as its innovation ponds and the green
areas are proposed for women called open
space and the black dash
lines of the indicative road structure
into the site
so badges hill were just the next slide
is obviously an important
issue in terms of this application
um to the center of the site um which is
designated as another site of wildlife
interest
the woodland is approximately 0.45
hectares woodland and categorized as
retained in moderate condition
the woodland is retained to be retained
as part of his proposal
during the course of the application the
ancient woodland specialist from denver
biodiversity records
has surveyed the woodland and confirms
that part of the woodland shown as um
section two on that plan
should be treated as a provisionally
ancient woodland
as i said the proposal would not result
in the direct loss of woodland however
without mitigation there would be impact
um it is proposed that the woodland
management plan is to be adopted as part
of the scheme
and will form part of the landscape and
ecological management plan to be
submitted and approved as part of the
reserve matters application
say next slide so as again there is a
tree preservation order which applies to
the trees present within woodland
woodland site say that area is in a
green hatched area to the left and that
is the actual original and the right
through preservation order showing um
the full extent of that tpo on that
privilege
and so the next slide is the apricot
agricultural assessment has been
submitted which completes the only tree
cover to be removed will be a small
number of trees
um identified as g6
located between the lower winds of the
cottage
to allow the construction of the linking
road access
additionally the southern hedgerow bank
is to be translated northwest to allow
the widening of the carriageway
and a number of existing trees
positioned within hydration for heavy
tank are to be removed through the
wiring process
none of the trees from the tree
preservation are actually affected by
the proposals
so just going on to the next slide
again this is outline but there is an
indicative framework indicating the
potential of approximately 11.07
hectares one site green infrastructure
incorporating deep natural green space
and
[Music]
[Music]
so just going on to a drainage plan so
the majority of the site falls within
five zone one which knows low
probability of flooding however the
chemistry watercourse is running south
to north through to the middle site
which has an associated area of risk of
flooding which is designated by two
three
the submitted um submitted big risk
assessment confirms a sequential
approach with the team's layout the area
of development is all within flood zone
one for any potential dwellings to be
erected on the site
um and the majority of the water courses
and associated blood cells are within
batches of wood which is not to be
developed
so on to the next slide
as i said there are two watercourses
running through the site through
badgersville wood watercourse one um
again um
the next slide shown substrate scheme is
proposed to manage the surface sorry
next slide
so a sudden drainage scheme is proposed
to manage to surface water drainage
while
home composing or
detention basins serving the catchments
within the site
as i said the technical officer is
present at this meeting as there are a
number of representations regarding
surface water and existing surface water
fighting problems within the locality
in terms of found drainage
foul drainage is to be disposed of by
the existing public sewer since
southwest water have raised their
objections
to this and confirmed any improvements
considered necessary will be undertaken
by them to ensure development can be
adequately trained
the last slide just sews on the
initiative master plan
to demonstrate how this might be
could be accommodated for up to 20.
so just going on to the planning
considerations
which are all detailed in your report
just as a summary
in terms of the principle of development
as you're aware the council as a council
we are not able to demonstrate five
housing supply
so the determination must be based on
the tilted balance which is a
presumption of the famous sustainable
development unless hard attached to the
proposal would significantly and
demonstrate the
benefits which investigates the policies
in the framework as a whole
um stages going on to validate character
and visual impact the site is not
covered by any national non-statutory
landscape
designations
as members will have seen the site has a
varied photography and is very steeply
sloping in places and unrelating in
others
the site is well covered by mature
hedgerow and tree belts within the
existing road lanes falling defendable
boundaries
an lbia was submitted in support of the
application
the lbia has been independently reviewed
by an independent landscape officer and
her conclusions are set out clearly in
the report
in summary summary she considers there
would be moderates to substantial
landscape change and she does disagree
to some extent the conclusions of the
lbia and confirms there will be some
residual non-state envisioned harm
it is identified that the proposal will
result in landscape change
as such i think it is important for
members to um
be clear that there is some conflict
with policy objectives particularly sc14
and dmr8a
which seeks to concern and enhance the
local distinctiveness and landscape
quality
of course it is noticed that parts of
the site can be seen within the context
or biddeford and that existing built
form and a reserved article application
would be able to secure litigation
measures
so going on to heritage and archaeology
there are no designated heritage aspects
within the site foundry there are a
number of listed buildings and scheduled
monuments within the sunny area
the council's conservation officer has
no objections to this application
equally the county council senior
historic officer has advised
that the archaeological features on the
site are not significant that they
should be preserved in situ
a pre-commencement condition is
recommended for a written scheme of
investigation and has been conditioned
as part of this recommendation
so residential immunity as is an outline
it is not consistent with this resulting
harmful impacts on residential amenities
or neighboring or future occupiers
providing
conditions recommended by the council's
environmental protection officer
decision
highways the progress development
includes access to detail consideration
at this stage
um first set out which includes two
vehicle access points from abusham road
each featuring a right-hand turn name
if we need a shared footway cycleway is
proposed along average from road to
provide that connecting team to
risk and drainage again a sequential
approach will be taken
to ensure that only areas conclude one
field
members have seen the proposal for the
surface water drainage strategy
the concerns raised by third parties are
noticed in reverse flooding and service
water drainage issues
however the technical quantities are
advising the lpa that the proposal
provisions for drainage the site are
technically acceptable
i recommend conditions to attach to any
recommendation
ecology and biodiversity the ecology
aspect of this site has been looked at
in huge detail
there are a number of ecology reports
conducted in 2016 2017 and 2020 which
provides a robust evidence base for
assessing the impact of the proposed
development on important features
identified on the application site and
beyond
an independent ecologist has reviewed
these studies and has requested further
ecological information
she has concluded providing the proposed
motivation measures are secured for
appropriately conditions the proposals
will meet the local national policy and
ecological legislation
the biodiversity gain is only indicative
this is only an outline application
however how a biodiversity net gain
being raised is greater than 10
this is partly due to the extensive
green space and mitigation enhancement
measures proposed for bachelor wood
viability and section 1 is six
obligations and the application has been
supported by a liability appraisal and
this has been externally reviewed by the
district foundation office
who has the outcome of this exercises
appended to your committee report which
i'm sure you have already
the conclusion of the district valuer is
that the scheme is not financially
viable when contributing to planning
commission requirements including first
affordable housing
there has been some compromise with the
applicant and the applicant has agreed
to provide 15 affordable housing on the
site which equates to 44 affordable
units
with the required section 106
contribution required
again um the district value has
instructed the viability review to be
agreed and that has been agreed by the
by the applicant in terms of um
re-looking at that viability and
reviewing that um
[Music]
if the application was um to proceed
so the planning balance in
as conclusion the fda or the council
cannot currently demonstrate five years
land supply of housing land to neatly
identify meaningful districts
it is there necessary to consider the
adverse impact of the proposal in fact
[Music]
in this instance the proposal would
provide a significant contribution to up
to up to 220 dwellings towards local
housing supply on a site which orders
the strategic central village
it should be noted that the proposal has
a range of benefits including vision of
on-site queen space
as well as a number of financial
constitutions towards health facilities
education provision and highway
improvements
turning to the adverse impacts as
discussed earlier the proposed
development
has been considered to change the
character of the site and the intact
development would have some adverse
landscape impact
however it is recognized that mitigation
measures exist which could reduce that
impact upon time but do not negate them
entirely
due to viability issues application is
unable to make a positive compliant
level of planning obligation
the district value has confirmed and the
local planning authority
has um agreed that the 15 affordable
housing across the site
um 40 units 44 years um being secured
so
i think this is another balanced
decision
where the benefits and harm have been
addressed
um it is your office's consideration
therefore there is a recommendation of
approval
uh which was made with the imposition of
planning conditions and section
obligations
i'm very sorry for that very long
presentation thank you for bearing with
me
thank you
thank you tracy thank you for that
comprehensive presentation
and our first speaker
speaking against this
is mr brownson
speaking against the application
i think he wants to stand up to give his
presentation
i'll tell you when the three minutes
start yeah because i'd have to say good
morning to you all thank you for
allowing me to speak on behalf of philip
farlow he's away on a holiday book nine
months ago so any questions i'm afraid
i'm reading his script right
35 years ago the kenworth valley was
identified as a vital green corridor
between the river and the sea
thus separating bitterford and northern
and a major effort has gone into
improving the natural environment within
the valley and it is now an important
ecosystem
the applicant claims biodiversity gain
on their site but this is based on
flawed assumptions
and treats the site as an indep as
independent of the rest of the valley
any ecosystem is like an elaborate
carpet
if you cut it up into little fragments
all you're left with is scraps of
useless material
the developer claims that unimproved
glass end has little value
however on the same area on the other
side of the valley
exhibits great biodiversity recent
surveys have shown over 40 different
fungi
some 80 or more bird species
125 spiders including some rare ones and
over 200 plant species
and it is a vital part of the mix which
is required to maintain the whole
kenworth valley ecosystem
the mitigation measures included in the
model are not evidence-based and have
little proven record of success
especially for facts and badgers
the assumptions around hedge rooms and
trees are based on leafy warwickshire in
central england
and not a north devon valley where
salt-laden winds blow in from the sea
one only has to look at the long time it
takes the trees to get established and
i've got a note here that tracy's got
some pictures of these
um
that's eight years old
the tree that should be double that
height you can see the length of time
it's taken to get established and
there's several more you can look at
them while i'm talking to you i still
should run it every three minutes
the developers have not bothered to
visit the reserve
and ask about the extensive range of
foreigner and flora records
all the expertise built up over 35 years
could it be that had they done so then
they would have found that their
application was doomed to failure on
purely environmental grounds
the biodiversity gain results that they
have predicted are given with species
accuracy
and no sensitivity analysis is offered
if their assumptions relying on a theory
as opposed to factual evidence prove
incorrect as they will be there will be
a major
bio diversity hit
and it'll be too late to do anything
available
the pandemic has also shown the value
over landscape green space and fresh air
to us all
the valley has been a vital walking
route and therapy for many people from
bradley ford bridge onwards and it is a
green devon [ __ ] within walking distance
of the tank
there are no buildings in view that do
not appear on the 1842 tide map
so this development would destroy the
ambiance
in conclusion all the brands were
rejecting the proposal three years ago
especially wildlife and landscape are
even more valid today
especially if one is concerned not only
for the environment but the mental and
physical health of the local population
thank you very much for listening thank
you
thank you mr sims and that was within
three minutes
yes
right the next contribution
that's speaking against
is a letter that sean will read out
their planning management readout from
christina blasey
thank you chair
can remember me no no
better yeah yeah okay
um a statement from
christina gracie
with reference to receipt of your email
dated 23rd december 2021 that's badly
above application we would request that
you read our objections as stated in our
email to your 10th of november
also we would like you to take the
following statement into account
building in the immediate billwood area
has been prolific during the past 10-15
years whilst everyone appreciates the
need for housing it is very often not
aimed at those in need of social housing
instead we more often than not find that
an x number of houses would be built
within with a miniscule percentage given
to social housing
this as far as we can see is the current
proposal for the intended application
above
over the years we have seen a sad
decline in the town of biddeford it has
become too many a poorly neglected and
foreign township shops lie empty with
uncom and chemtech
which in turn leads to a lack of pride
and appreciation by the town's people
we feel that whilst tourism is an
important part of our town
those who visit the town are very
disappointed with seeing our high street
often the most important and sought
after area when holiday makers arrive
we have an outer town retail outlet but
this has only served to take away a lot
of trade from billy for town itself
where revenue is much needed
to build more houses without good
infrastructure is surely putting the car
before the horse
we no longer have a working hospital and
the minor injuries unit has been closed
for the last 18 months and is likely to
remain so
thus leaving anyone with an emergency to
have to travel almost half of our
journey to barnstable northern district
hospital
this is a major concern for most of
town's residents
either young or old the journey can
still mean a difference between life and
death
unemployment in the area is high and we
have no real prospect of that changing
anytime soon
to be able to get more houses between
londonderry farm and average and village
is not justified it's pure greed on
behalf of developers who while spouting
how wonderful and balanced ever it will
be
in reality as has been seen in the past
this will not necessarily be the case
how many times has housing planning
permission been granted on the proviso
that so many of the new dwellings will
be given social housing
which as a later stage is often being
withdrawn or altered and the guys of
cost-effectiveness
residents of londonderry farm and global
place do not need yet another huge
development being undertaken in such
close proximity
there would be massive inconvenience to
both pedestrian and motorists and lie
not to mention very importantly the
devastations report to our wildlife
thank you for reading this we hope it
will give food for thought on this very
contentious issue he was faithfully
christina and jeff gracie
thank you sean
and then we have
speaking in supporters the applicant
stuart carmel please
if you'd like to come up
and you've three minutes to address the
committee thank you you speak straight
into the
mr chairman
let's just ask is he the agent yeah
because his name's not on the
support sheer carbon support
applications
clarify so i worked for global
development the applicant is um
um so firstly thank you very much to the
chair of the chair and thank you for the
officers of her recommendation and a
very comprehensive presentation
and this recommendation follows the
discussions between the applicant office
of the council and statutory consultants
to ensure all matters will carefully
consider an address on and off site both
pre and post application
the application will provide a range of
house types and an identity to ensure
smaller properties provided including 44
units of affordable housing
the proposal is in keeping with the
existing pathways
and the development has responded to the
matters ranked by landscape officers
as with any site including allocated
sites
there's always going to be a change from
undeveloped nature to that built form as
considered by the officer reports a
proposed fund will change the character
of the site and there will be some
limited landscape impacts these are
mitigated through new hedgerow new
hedgerow and tree plant
this is a green infrastructure and
public open space government with over
11 hectares provided on sites
to which there is currently no public
access
management will be provided for
protected species and trees and
hedgerows on site including that
and regarding transport and travel the
site proposes the conversion of osborne
lane to a walking site for your group as
well as shared division on the site from
the jump throughout the site section
section one of six contributions will
also be provided to the camera value
cycle route and the a39 junction safety
improvements
the application proposes the extension
of the 30 mile an hour limit along
average road and reducing speeds as the
vehicles come into pitch along with
building frontage
and all these measures along with the
travel plan will help encourage
movements by sustainable modes
in relation to drainage the site will be
able to effectively manage watermelons
controlling discharge and upgrading
existing culvert within the site which
will help address the issues that have
been raised about offside flooding
issues
and there's also significant
contributions to the section 106 to
libraries new educational facilities a
new community hall and contribution to
the north and swimming pool and 3g
artificial penetration benefits
the council cannot the council cannot
currently demonstrate a flight this
flight as such as a media immediately
needs to grant them this and to which
this site
will be able to contribute significantly
the effort is expected in the
development plan deliver over 4 000
dwellings
but if it is the strategic assembly
identified in the policies and as such
the officer report confirms the site is
consistent with the spatial strategy of
the local plan
as such there's need to grant units of
benefit to meet this requirement which
your officers have carefully considered
as addressed sustainably through
delivery of assault
granting a planning commission brings
about a number of benefits have been
differed in the wider district in
accordance with the development plan as
such i would respectfully ask you for
legal office's recommendations
thank you
thank you mr clavo thank you
right that concludes the contributions
from the public to this
the final decision we've got on the
balance that we've got to
look at between
the benefits of this scheme
and there's not having this five-year
housing land supply and the dis benefits
of it the loss of this ancient woodland
site now
i'll let somebody set the ball rolling
but personally
i've got some great problems
with this
but i'll leave it at that afternoon
thank you um
well i've got six issues with this one
um the first one is not in the local
plan
this area
in fact i remember this one it came
forward almost in the last week i think
before we signed off the local plan it's
a very very late
and you'll notice in our on our plans
today it does say withdrawal
in i think it's october of 2018 and we
signed off at the beginning of december
um
it's gone up since then from 260 to 290
houses
uh the second point is both local
councils who involve both abhishem and
biddeford are very strongly against it
i did look at the public consultation
actually because i was intrigued
because there are many many objectives
on our website
when they did the public consultation
there were only nine people replied
i'd love to have read the letters but
they're all totally redacted uh so you
can't actually read and even the
developer agrees that they weren't all
wholly in favor i don't know what it
means because you can't see them
the third point is um the site in
relation to biddeford because
it was interesting to see photographs
what it looks like from londonderry or
looks like from inside the field
the major impact is from the link road
where i have to say at the moment if you
drive along the link row londonderry
sticks out
like a huge intrusion into the
countryside
all the trees have lost their leaves it
really does
stick out enormously and this will only
accentuate it be right up to the link
road
we heard from our planning officer about
the um the problems
with the
um landscape the devon county officer i
just read out what he said actually bill
she i'm not sure if it is but
i remain in disagreement with the main
conclusion of the landscape valuation
that development can be accommodated at
the site without causing material harm
to joining site or townscape
in my opinion there will be residual
landscape and visual harm that's in
heavy type as described above
being weighed against the benefits of
the scheme
so clearly there are problems there um
torridge's
comments were fascinating because on
page 127 they talk about this
it says a development of up to 200
dwellings will be in accordance with the
local plan a hierarchical approach to
locate development within the district's
most major segment
within biddeford this is stuck on the
edge
i've used the analogy before that bit of
beginning to resemble a tuber toothpaste
it's being squeezed out and it's going
right east-west there's no development
north-south and uh
this i think would really accentuate
that
um my fourth point the environmental
impacts
now firstly flooding now this area is in
a critical drainage area we know that
because we've told that
water from the site
enters the chemwith valley
and apparently it's all going to be
dealt with the sites
now i've said before i don't trust certs
but we all know we had a problem at
morton
where the suds failed and the garages
were flooded the mp got involved it was
a huge disaster and
now the environment agency we're going
to raise the height of the kennedy dam
they've walked away from that now and
yet here at torres we're faced with
development
completely around the kenwood valley
stretching from rose hill 250 houses
daven
um this estate winsford morton
londonderry itself
the whole valley is going to be
surrounded by
um
development and we all know
you know there's going to be a lot of
water flying off that land can the suns
handle i don't think they can
uh the area floods very badly already if
any of you have ever been down there
during the flight you'll know
it's completely impassable
um
the african
actually
in one very interesting statement it's
on page 102 if you want to see it they
agree that the underlying soil has very
low infiltration rates
when i read that i thought well that's
not going to help studs is it
again another environment for the
background after the floods the woods
now it's a very unusual woodland it's i
have been to it i went to a long time
ago um it's a very strange place
actually it has a real atmosphere of it
but
if you read the
statements that come out uh the ancient
woodland specialist from devon
biodiversity record center has surveyed
that would learn state that part of the
woodland
should be treated provisionally as
ancient women we don't have much of that
in north devon
i have to say
the idea that
access to the woodland is going to be
allowed both north south and east west a
pathway going through it
basically it means any amelioration
that's
put forward for this site uh is
laughable
i mean if you go to londonderry next
door where there's a similar site
actually it's a ravine
uh that was left
i'm afraid i've been sent pictures and
if you go there you all know about it
some of the surrounding houses use it as
a rubbish tongue
and they're not even allowed into that
site
there is it is fenced off this one isn't
going to be allowed you think how long
is that woodland going to last
um on page 146 says talk of a
biodiversity game i go back to what
council
leather said earlier i think this one in
this case is totally spurious
you've got a bit of ancient woodland
you're going to build a state round and
allowed everyone's going i'm not you
know you know what the kids will do you
know what will happen to them the third
point about the environment nearby sites
and when i read the report on page 129
it says the aomd
uh is 800 meters away
well the kenworth valley nature reserve
which i got set up quite a few years ago
that's 700 meters away this is our own
figures by the way from page 141 uh the
uh godbrown castle county wildlife site
is 130 meters away and the cornbread
bird reserve is less than 100 meters
away
now i know that reserve actually planted
trees there many years ago
um
and yet it's taken us oh no there's no
problem i think well that can't be right
again the fifth point i'm sorry to delay
this schools
uh 1.3 million and i have checked the
figures sean it is 1.3 million on this
site uh it's been requested by demon
county and again
where are the schools going to go you
know
what are we doing again
uh i have to point out that londonderry
is 300 houses it was going to have a
school never got built
moreton park the most recent development
there is 200 houses this site is going
to add another 290. that's 790 houses
without any new school
and yet i'll probably be told oh they're
going to give some money towards
democracy certainly all right and the
last point i'm sure you'd be glad to
hear
the viability study this was interesting
one because
the developer offered 10 percent
affordable and even just through value
i've disagreed quite strongly with this
it's gone up to 15
but what i can't understand the reason i
ask the agent who he represents
is that the applicant
is gladman's but it's also the owner
of the field and again in the viability
study
uh land values they vary because the
disregard of disagreed between 4.6
million and 3.8 million
and you think wait wait a minute how can
the
owner of the land hope this is a figure
when they already own them
and yet this is set against the
viability study
and i can't follow that
uh on page 174
there's a fascinating one i've never
seen before the district value has
struck it out but i will just highlight
it because i found it really intriguing
and developing their viability study
they quoted 1.3 million
for future home standards
well it's not actually legally
enforceable yet
district value has picked it up as well
as crossed it out and i thought that's
fascinating you know if elon musk has
his way we'll all add rocket pads in
their thigh houses perhaps we should
start pointing for that you know you
think you can't quote for future stuff
that is
how you do that
um the other one
and uh this is
a small one but page 140 it quotes 300
000 pounds to improve the a39 junction
for the buckling roads this is that mill
development
you're thinking
this development here has nothing to do
with battery road how come gavin county
yet again
uh raising money and i would have
thought dad
moore was they've got enough houses
there to pay for that on their own the
other one is and i'm very sad to say
this there's three hundred thousand
pounds for the kenworth valley cycleway
which i've been going on about for years
however
when i sit on active travel and the lc
wood groups we know that the landowners
point at a stated point blank they're
not going to sell the land to us so
300 000 pounds in there
probably
won't go anywhere
and i'm just wondering where that would
go and whether we could start putting
this money at six hundred thousand
pounds there on roads should it go
towards more affordable homes but as it
stands i think there are so many points
against this scheme that i am going to
vote against
thank you councilman christine
anybody else counsellor law
i cannot possibly follow what uh cancer
christie said very early picked up and
said what
i was gonna pick up i was also going to
ask about dcc highways
and the kepler cycle route i was going
to ask how that
splits how that money was going to be
split 610 000 and as captain christie
said and if local and low landowners
won't give their permission then the
cycle way
won't happen and that's happened on
various parts of the target trade as
well so i was about that query
um
going on to the dv report
i also studied what the heading what
come under the headed at all costs and i
also picked up about the 4 500 pound for
each of the 290 dwellings
and i wondered where that was gonna go
and then there was sixty thousand six
hundred and forty four pounds for just
two bus stops
so i picked
that
um
ecology report i thought was very good
and i read it and i downloaded it and
i've read it so i do agree with the
apology report
um if you turn now to page hundreds full
paragraph down
i'm saying this talking cheaper that
might be this week
with their paragraphs
of parish councils report
complaints about traffic congestion on
the narrow video
vote as far back as 1894
[Music]
um
well from my point of view if you want
to
see the destruction of ancient woodland
you want to vote to support this
application because that's what will
happen
um it's already been mentioned that it's
going to have pathways for it for the
public to use there's no access to the
public
in that
wonderful wildlife area which should be
retained in my view
but some of it will be fenced if you've
got whatever wildlife's there now won't
be there within five years of any
housing being built close by i could
almost guarantee that
and
i was a bit intrigued reading on page
104 about
all this about the costs for the
junction in buckley robot that's almost
been completed now traffic lights are
there street lighting's up um
why they should be asking for money
towards that beyond me uh it's all it's
almost it must be out of date now
um
i've got plenty of policy reasons why
why this can be reviewed
manchester badges hillwood is woodland
priority habitat patient 11
then according to the information
submitted
designated as a site of nature
conservation interests
this is this for me throughout this
report right the application is what
matters
is the destruction of potential
destruction of this wonderful wildlife
asset close to the center
we all know that
without this
five-year housing land supply which we
can't currently
this wouldn't have come anywhere near
getting
approved for planning
um
and ultimately
some of the uh comments from people talk
about lack of community consultation on
this particular latest application
and then
when you look at the
the county
officer
on page 131 at the bottom development in
the most visually sensitive northwest
and western areas i previously stated
that i do not consider that the site
offers capacity to accommodate
development in these areas
the proposal to make these areas
single-story would make no difference
the site would still have an urban
developed character as opposed to an
undeveloped green character so would not
address this fundamental issue and that
really is
to me the core of this up my objections
to this site is that
you will be changing what is now a
wonderful wildlife area close to
biddeford
which as councilman christie's pointed
out i think we all know
going over the chemistry you look across
the big sheep have got their sign their
about their activities and you see the
site behind and it is a wonderful green
site with
the comb of the valley with the ancient
woodland in it and this
application would destroy all that
there's no doubt and it's a key route
through to kevin's valley for wildlife
to cross over north general which
actually
it's not a road it's a very narrow lane
along there and it is very plo problems
are flooding carpet because i know i've
driven into it in the dark before then
um
so i'm going to be opposed to this and
i'm going to move that is refugee
reviews
and i've got some of the reasons listed
here
um
it's contrary to me contrary to mppf 174
little a and b
mpbf 180 c little c
st 14 of our local plan enhancing
environmental assets
on page 58 there at g
little g i and d
dm a biodiversity and geo-diversity
little bracket seven
ancient woodland on page
421 of our
local plan here
so for those reasons
looking at the utility balance which
we've got is the main consideration for
this
it's open countryside
and the tilted balance for me is far too
damaging
to the environment to allow it to happen
and that's
where everybody's been screaming about
affordable hours
13 on that side
this side got 44.
now if do we want to fall of 11 or not
so and for me
i think the tilted balance is in favor
of
this application
i i understand about wildlife i live
around wildlife
so so yeah
i can't agree with it
it was just a comment on the um
um
affordable housing side of it now if i'm
reading this right talk about the
residual land value of 10 times the
agricultural value
and so they put the agriculture value of
10 thousand pounds which is
now
if this land is outside of the
development boundary anybody
how can it actually be deemed to be
worth 10 times agricultural value
um so i would have thought that i mean
if if someone migrate if i was offered
ten times what my land is worth for
buildings on it i would think i'm
wonderful so um
given that
you know given that this is outside the
development boundary anyway how is that
worth 10 times the agricultural value
and if that was
if that was like you could take some
money off of that to put that towards
affordable housing
then you would still be left with a good
you know a good
that's just what it's been valued at i
suppose
it is a uplift i know
but to pick up on councillor watson's
point
and he compared it with the previous
application the previous previous
application is in our local plan the
whole site is in our local plan this is
open countryside on the edge of benefit
and it's a very valuable green space
close to military and you've heard
you'll see all the comments on the
website the objections a lot of
objections to it making these very
points that i did about the loss of the
ecology of baghdad
and the wildlife corridor that this
provides through down to kenwood's power
and it is all intellect like those mr
sims
uh moved into that
but just across the road from this side
across abbott's room there is set 71
hectares
of land in our local plan for
development for a mixed development for
housing and businesses
so we're not actually sure
[Music]
i must disagree with that last statement
because we all know that we've got to
look what is in front of us you cannot
think we've got 75 acres that might be
developing the next 10 years we've got
to consider what's in front of us and we
further know that if there's one
objection or a thousand objections
it's immaterial and as long as they an
application fits planning quality that's
what you should make a decision on not
on a number of objections or
i i don't make my decisions on the
number of objections
you just stress they have any injections
yeah i do
when we sit here on behalf of the public
looking at planning applications
it doesn't matter how many applications
are how many objections or
letters of support come in and it does
matter to the planning reasons that they
raise in those objections or in their
support it matters
and it matters to me that many of those
objections
have been in line with what i've been
saying about the loss of this site and
that
and for me it's detrimental to the area
to lose a green fuel site with ancient
woodland
anyway we've had two
um
two proposals the first proposal was
that this is refused and i didn't give
the reasons i can go over them again if
you like and councillor christie
seconded
so kirsty will you take the vote on that
please refuse yes thank you chair
councillor belton against
councillor brown
councillor christie or
councillor craby or
[Music]
thank you
so that's four four chairs and five
again
i did five four and four again
which is to improve this
um which was proposed by council watson
yeah certainly by council alone
so could you take the vote from that to
improve this change please
thank you chair council about him
the first vote was 5'4
yeah just to clarify i have the same
result as kirstie so the first one we
had four four and five again so that
motion was lost and for the second one
we had four four and five again so that
motion was was lost as well
so which motion stands the last one
neither they've both both been voted
against
yes but the last vote was the last the
last one was to approve it
it was yes
and the first one and the motion to
refuse was lost
by the war as well
the applications
so
i thought we had councillor brown
originally myself councillor christian
council mcguffin councillor craig
that was fine
okay
i've been chairman of torridge and i
thought under our constitution the last
vote was the one that stood
but the motion was lost so
it was the second one was for approval
no the second one the second one for
approval was lost yes the first one for
reviews or was lost as well
but surely the second vote being the
final though must be the one that stands
well yeah it says i'm concerned
[Music]
don't make sense
chair whilst we'll wait can we just wait
to continue the meeting because we're up
to 12 20. well
i'll propose we can continue the meeting
seconded by
councillor christie come in vote to
extend making things
because you just start you have to ask
everybody
oh
[Music]
thank you
a short break for two minutes
while the league
before because somebody changed their
mind and decided they weren't going to
improve it
listen counselor mcdonald thank you
just
i don't know about two votes there's no
clarity with it
at the moment so why don't we just take
those two votes again to get pure
clarity
everyone's in the room and uh character
counts with rounds and start to change
your mind
you can't put pressure on anybody but
we're not clear we haven't come to a
decisive decision at the moment so
why don't you just take the first vote
again and take a second
mind they may create the clarions that
we need mindful that this is being
broadcast from publicly keep chopping
and changing so that's for transparency
surely we're at stairway
what do we do
i think i think tracy
[Music]
oh
okay
[Music]
is
okay
um
okay
[Music]
still
[Music]
right
[Music]
over and above what was mentioned before
of the wider landscape impact that this
development would have
um
in the area that is an additional reason
about what was said when i first
proposed to refuse it
and we
with the reasons originally
the additional ones of the the effect of
the development on the wider landscape
which wasn't mentioned when i first in
the first refusal was put forward so how
do we legally negate the first two
one way or the other so
i'm proposing that the additional
landscape issue is added into the reason
to refuse
and we vote on that then
how can we start adding things to
something that we've already taken
because it's impression on just a minute
it's the last vote that counts i'm sorry
but you know if you start saying yes we
can re-run it
it creates all sorts of mr chairman on
the point of order then please
listen to clarify please before we
proceed any further yeah i accept what
members are saying
the difficulty that you've got so we've
had a motion to refuse the application
that wasn't carried and the votes for
that was four or five and then you had a
contrary motion to approve and again
that wasn't carried
that the votes for for that were four
and it was five again so we are in in
limbo it hasn't been approved and it
hasn't been a refuse both of the motions
that were put forward haven't been
approved by members so
i understand what you're saying
counselor christie but it hasn't been
approved at this stage it hasn't been
refused so
um
members are entitled to put forward an
amendment to a motion now but other than
that we're in limbo at this stage
i'm going to make the chairman's
decision on listening
the last vote stands this application
has been refused
because it was refused approval on the
last book
and as far as the committee is concerned
the last one is what counts
otherwise
otherwise we can keep chopping and
changing all the way through
if an extra conditions put forward to
refuse there might be an extra condition
put forward then to improve it
i'm going to keep going backwards and
forwards and i do think the last law
obviously one of the committee members
decided to change their mind and they
couldn't support approval
therefore it's failed and it's not been
approved in michael
i'm going to move on
this has been refused because approval
was refused
okay sure i think you're correct sorry i
think you're correct but can i go back
to something i raised about the
applicant
is also the owner of the land and yet in
their viability study
they put the
the sale of the land against the
viability in the viability studies of
cost
they they want their cake and eat it
is that how what is this legal standing
on that
check
do not give some advice
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that's the lock or customer
i'm against i want this in the public
domain so there's no come back to any of
us
councillor watson i'm in games
that's the wise man